autre défi communiste ou communisants
vérité d'hommes semblables les niveaux
[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue pour cette première
chronique de scopeo je m'appelle etienne
et je vous propose aujourd'hui que nous
plongions l'espace d'un moment au coeur
du mouvement anarchiste révolutionnaire
à travers le livre de michel bakounine
intitulé dieu et l'état
[Musique]
à
l'anarchisme fait partie de ces
doctrines politiques vivent des vivaces
dont certains se revendique et beaucoup
parlent trop souvent malheureusement
sans savoir d'où viennent les idées
qu'ils aiment à placer sur leur
piédestal mental cette chronique a
vocation à soutenir les aspirants
anarchiste tout aussi bien que leurs
ennemis les plus radicaux éclairer les
étudiants ou tout simplement les
amoureux des idées et de leurs origines
comprendre l'origine des idées dans le
texte
voilà la seule raison d'être de cette
série de chroniques que vous propose
scopeo les opinions et réflexions
exprimées dans ces chroniques ne feront
que retranscrire fidèlement la pensée de
l'auteur dont il est question tout en
proposant parfois quelques pistes de
réflexion alternative
[Musique]
michael alexandrowicz bakounine né en
1814 dans un petit village de l'est de
la russie figure de la théorisation
moderne du courant anarchiste
collectiviste contemporain de marx
engels et proudhon est avant tout un
intellectuel
oui mais un intellectuel de combat bien
loin de chercher à résumer l'ensemble de
la vie et des écrits de l'auteur nous
nous concentrerons ici sur la direction
précise de cet ouvrage plié de
l'anarchisme radical proposant une
vision sans concession de la religion et
de l'état
considérés comme les deux intrus à
abattre
[Musique]
ce petit livre d'une centaine de pages
est à n'en pas douter dans la droite
ligne de la dialectique matérialiste
socialiste du début du 19e siècle
la lecture est facile limpide le ton est
volontairement pamphlétaire
l'argumentation est solide et structurée
comme souvent chez les auteurs du
courant socialiste révolutionnaire la
forme sert la toute puissance du fonds
bakounine ne se perd pas en
ratiocinations est entre très rapidement
dans le vif de son propos tâchons donc
de faire de même
c'est ouvre
destiné à n'être qu'une introduction un
plus grand travail qui restera inachevé
la productivité de bakounine fut
fortement freiné par ses voyages à
travers l'europe à la recherche de la
moindre révolte sociale
cherchant à observer la révolution dans
ce qu'elle a de terriblement intime et
vivante dieu et l'état débute par
quelques précisions doctrinal rien de
réellement nouveau pour quiconque est
habitué à la dialectique matérialiste
mais qui peuvent toutefois s'avérer
troublante pour des esprits moins
familiers à ce type décrit la colline
des pins l'homme avant toute
considération extérieur comme un animal
très proche de ses voisins les bêtes
mais doté de deux facultés absolument
essentiel et que l'on retrouvera tout au
long de l'ouvragé
la première est assez classique en
réalité il s'agit de la faculté de
penser
la seconde est plus inhabituel il s'agit
du besoin de se révolter
la première révolte écrit cyniquement
bakounine et la désobéissance
théologique dans la cueillette du fruit
défendu de la science soufflé à
l'oreille dave par satan en personne
autrement dit l'homme a fait le premier
pas vers son humanité par la
désobéissance à ce propos bakounine
écrit satan l'éternel révolté le premier
libre penseur et l'émancipation des
mondes il fuit on à l'homme de son
ignorance et de son obéissance bestial
il l'émanciper et imprime sur son front
le sceau de la liberté et de l'humanité
en le poussant à désobéir et à manger du
fruit de la science mais qu'on ne s'y
trompe pas
bakounine ne fait ici que de s'amuser
des mythes et symboles chrétiens
lesquels pour lui ne représente que 2
ridicule histoire inventée par les
hommes et pour les hommes
bien loin de toutes considérations
théologiques la religion est en réalité
un concept qui en lui-même est absurde
pourquoi un être si parfait que dieu se
serait-il abc a créé l'homme
voilà la question à laquelle aucun
métaphysicien aucun philosophe aucun
théologien ni aucun poète
jamais pu et ne pourra probablement
jamais répondre bakounine pense que la
religion c'est avant tout croire en
l'absurde mais au fond tout aurait pu
s'arrêter là
critique de la doctrine religieuse
rejettent la théologie vu et revu me
direz vous oui mais encore aurait-il
fallu que la religion ne soit pas le
premier ennemi sur le chemin de
l'humanisation comprenez de la
révolution socialiste
[Musique]
tu veux bâtir décidé idéal détruit
d'abord les monstruosités gouvernement
caserne cathédrale qui sont pour nous
autant d'absurdités dès aujourd'hui
vivons le communisme zen groupon que par
affinités notre bonheur
naîtra de la halle truies
désir soit des réalités
ou compagnons de misère
l'heure est venue
pour nous révolter que le son coup et
rougissent la terre n'est que ce soit
pour notre liberté
c'est que des feux ce passionné
[Musique]
nous voici donc avec un peuple
pensé comme opprimés et rabaissé mû par
cet instinct fondamental de s'en sortir
de transcender sa condition
devant lui s'offre trois voies dont deux
fictives pour tenter de s'élever et de
sortir de sa condition tragique et
honteuse il va devoir choisir une de ces
trois voix les deux premières fictive
encore une fois son la religion le
cabaret comprenait la soumission à dieu
et la fuite dans la frivolité et les
plaisirs inutile et une dernière cette
fois ci bien réel
la révolution les deux premières
solutions fictive doivent être combattus
avec hargne pour que puisse émerger la
troisième salvatrice la soumission à
dieu empêche toute révolte
le cabaret n'en parlons pas la religion
dans la pensée de bakounine n'est donc
pas juste un écueil de l'esprit c'est
une menace fondamentale pour
l'aboutissement de ce qu'il appelle
l'humanisation de l'homme est un très
grand danger pour sa liberté
d'où découle logiquement la nécessité de
l'éradiquer totalement mais nous
reviendrons un peu plus tard sur ce
point pour l'instant retenez simplement
que tant que les cultes existeront les
hommes auront le droit ou au moins la
possibilité de croire ce qui bien
entendu pour bakounine est totalement
inenvisageable pour pouvoir détruire
l'idée même de religion de sacré il faut
selon l'anarchiste expliqué à l'homme
comment et pourquoi cette idée se
manifeste dans son système nerveux
c'est la seule manière de détruire ce
que bakounine appel l'absurdité
religieuse il faut décortiquer et dénudé
cette erreur historique
alors décortiquons
[Musique]
nous voici donc avec une religion qui
comme dit précédemment est une création
de l'homme qui n'est pas encore parvenu
à maturité intellectuelle
l'homme crée donc le ciel en le dotant
d'un sens renversant sa propre image
d'homme terrestre cherchant à échapper
d'une certaine manière à sa propre
condition
voilà donc le petit homme qui crée le
grand dieu
cette création
cette figuration des cieux dirait ton de
manière un peu pédante une fois terminée
la grande machine est alors lancé dieu
est proclamé la cause de l'homme dans
une forme de salto anthropologique d'un
konin écrit à ce sujet l'homme après
l'avoir tiré du néant à son insu
s'agenouille devant dieu l'adorent et se
proclame sa créature et son esclave
fermer la citation en réalité cette idée
servitude volontaire n'est pas très
original on la retrouve déjà c'est
plusieurs auteurs dont bien évidemment
la boétie
mais ce qui va nous intéresser c'est
peut-être l'ultime critique que fait
bakounine à la religion dans la
confection de son système philosophique
mais pour l'heure résumons
si dieu et l'homme est esclave or
l'homme doit être libre donc dieu
n'existe pas voilà en quelques mots le
soubassement philosophique de la pensée
anti religieuse de bakounine
comment expliquer le pouvoir
d'attraction des religions pour répondre
à cette question il faut commencer par
dire que toutes les religions se valent
pas à ce titre de toutes les religions
celle qui a su pour bakounine lemieux
usek de la faiblesse des hommes pour se
répandre et affirmer son hégémonie
liberticide est sans doute la religion
chrétienne
c'est ce que bakounine appel
l'incontestable mérite de cette religion
s'être adressé à un public immense et
souffrent
dominés par une aristocratie perpétuelle
qui lui déniait même le simple principe
de droit ou de dignité
la religion chrétienne a donc trouvé
cette masse de miséreux à travers
l'humanité et il l'a transformé en
terreau fertile pour prêcher sa doctrine
cette dernière convenait en apparence
totalement à la foule elle consoler les
mécontents de la vie apaiser la soif du
coeur et qu'on tentait la pauvreté de
l'esprit tout en instaurant petit à
petit des préceptes absurde et
monstrueux la religion chrétienne répond
aux attentes des opprimés en calmant
l'ordre révolte par quelques contes et
légendes en eau glissant par ailleurs la
pauvreté vie dans les esprits de toute
la foule du désespoir
comprenez bien la fougue du désespoir où
cette espèce de baroud d'honneur
populaire l'énergie du désespoir est
absolument nécessaire à tous les
révolutionnaires qu'il soit anarchistes
ou non d'ailleurs car sans ce désespoir
tout projet de révolte ou même de
révolution bien évidemment est à exclure
définitivement
on pourrait presque dire que la religion
vol la révolte aux révolutionnaires la
propagande chrétienne comme l'appelle
bakounine a donc visé le coeur et dans
l'esprit répondantes des aspirations
éternelle est bien légitime à des
besoins vitaux mais sans réelle
intention d'y répondre à des souffrances
à l' esclavage mais elle ne répond
certainement pas à la raison car
rappelons le encore une fois la religion
et pour bakounine absolument absurde
elle ne possède donc aucune forme de
porosité avec la logique et la raison
froide
pire ces deux derniers un risquerait de
révéler ses contradictions évidentes et
son absence totale de logique
en revanche la religion catholique ainsi
que toutes les autres religions
s'accommode parfaitement des élans du
coeur ce faisant
voilà l'homme renonçant à sa liberté
abdiquant de sa raison et se préparant à
l' esclavage
bakou
conclut qui veut d'adorer dieu doit sans
se faire depuis riz l'illusion renoncer
bravement à sa liberté et à son humanité
[Musique]
e
ce qui est intéressant avec la manière
dont d'un coup ils pensent la religion
au-delà des critiques formulées qui
reste somme toute assez classique c'est
que nous pouvons y trouver un exemple
extrêmement parlant de cette fameuse
idée souvent débattu dans les
amphithéâtres de sciences politiques du
sens de l'histoire principe hégélien
servant de base à toute l'argumentation
socialiste la religion est envisagée
comme une erreur mais une erreur
nécessaire presque inévitable elle
correspond en réalité à l'errance des
croyances de l'homme dans son stade dit
bestial la religion et la croyance en
dieu sont donc une étape de la
bestialité vers l'humanité vers la
lumière de l'esprit
derrière nous notre animalité et devant
nous notre humanité
l'homme de demain sera meilleur que
celui d'aujourd'hui car il aura laissé
de côté ses croyances millénaire
bakounine explique que l'ancienneté
d'une idée devrait toujours nous la
rendre suspecte
d'où l'utilité de questionner en
profondeur le rôle de la religion
croyances antique et pérenne par
excellence toujours nous retourner vers
notre passé mais qu'on s'entende bien
pas pour y revenir
évidemment simplement pour regarder ce
que nous avons cru naïvement et ce vers
quoi nous ne vont plus à l'est mais une
question reste cependant toujours en
suspens vers quoi conduit la religion
que provoque l'adoration d'un dieu
absolument absurde et bien ce sont les
deux questions auxquelles nous allons
maintenant tâcher de répondre
[Musique]
nous voici donc avec une religion
castrant les velléités révolutionnaires
prohibant toute idée de révolte privant
l'homme de sa liberté de l'essence même
de l'accomplissement de son humanité
abrutissante aussi accusé de corrompre
la justice des hommes de déshonorer le
travail
mais toutes ces critiques restent en
réalité peu intéressante pour nous
cependant un des points kaman baconing
est beaucoup plus intéressant il parle
d'une religion presque vampirique toutes
les religions sont absolument cruel car
fondées sur un principe de soumission
sur le sens et le sacrifice
l'immolation perpétuelle de l'humanité
pour satisfaire la vengeance divine plus
l'idée de dieu se renforce plus il
devient grand et plus l'humanité devient
misérables et rabougri voilà la clé
peu importe que dieu soit 10 12 ou
libérale il reste ce grand vampire sur
plan bon l'homme aspire en toute
humanité et toute liberté
dieu aspire tout ce qu'il y a de bons de
grandes merveilleux dans l'homme et se
l'approprient l'humanité terrestre
devient alors un caniveau où rien de
grand et de somptueux ne reste bien
longtemps la terre et spoiler de son
génie et de sa poésie par ces grand
barbu ou ce grand barbu mais ne vous
avisez pas de penser que notre société
sécularisée et à la religion majoritaire
visiblement déclinante serait d'une
certaine manière sortie de ce grand
mouvement ce n'est pour bakounine
absolument pas le cas car si dieu comme
entité chargée d'une théologie complexe
et largement approuvée par la population
semble mort l'idée de dieu vidé de
touche à tout agencement théologiques au
mythique reste terriblement présent
c'est ce que bakounine appelle dieu et
rien d'autre posture classique des
idéalistes et intellectuels en tout
genre ces sommes trop intelligent
pour avaler facilement toute l'absurdité
de la mystique religieuse mais manquant
cependant de courage pour récuser
complètement et jusqu'à la fin l'idée
divine dans la bouche de ces pseudos
intellectuels idéaliste venu remplacer
des prêtres des hommes d'église dieu
devient le nom générique de tout ce qui
est beau et grand l'homme et spoiler de
la production de saab est formidable
intelligence dieu devient alors une idée
opaque et plus ou moins vide en dehors
de toutes considérations positives qui
risqueraient en réalité de le soumettre
à une critique néfastes
on ne dit pas si dieu est personnelle ou
un personnel
si la craie ou non le monde si
l'influent même éventuellement sur ce
monde
dieu est rien laure dieu est donc
totalement inattaquable puisqu'il est
juste un mot et une idée dieu ces grands
esprits rend à l'asservissement des
masses évidemment en prétendant faire le
contraire refuse à l'homme toutes
qualités trop importante
ils sont incapables d'accepter une
réalité anthropologique basique
l'homme est capable du meilleur comme du
pire on les imaginerait presque hurler
refusant que les grands esprits qu'ils
admirent soit aussi soumis aux terribles
impératifs biologiques allant de la
défécation à la maladie ou que c'est
même esprit qu'il considère comme divin
puisse voler violer ou mentir
quand j'étais gosse que je feuilletais
l'ancien testament raconter aux enfants
est illustré de gravures de gustave doré
je voyais le pont du sur un même site
est un vieux monsieur il avait déçu on
est longue par jean zay cayenne une
bouche il devait aussi menti et s'ils
mangeaient il fallait aussi je les ai
testés mais cette année m'effrayer usto
car j'avais beau être d'une famille
plutôt je sentais qualité des intercités
2 une des places les manoirs sans la
moindre préparation théologique
spontanément l'enfant que j'étais d'un
homme comprenez donc qu'il y ait qu il y
à un compatibilité entre la merde et du
et par conséquent la fragilité la thèse
fondamentale de l'anthropologie de celle
selon laquelle l'homme a été créé
qui tue deux choses ou bien l'homme a
été fait un match tendu et alors dû à
des intestins bien dieu n'a pas
d'intérêt ni l'homme ne lui ressemble
pas les anciens une stick nous en termes
aussi clairement mois commence dans ma
5e
sans trancher ce problème à l'antenne
grands maîtres de maintenance du 12e
siècle affirmait que justement je buvais
ne peut fait quel point la merde est un
problème théologique plus ardue que le
mal dieu a donné la liberté un homme et
en plus nombreux et l'admettre qui n'est
pas responsable des dilemmes de
l'humanité et la responsabilité la merde
qui ont entièrement à celui qui les
nomme et à lui seul
les grandes choses doivent quitter
l'humanité pourquoi et bien pour
rejoindre le royaume divin tout
simplement
en effet sauf à courir le risque d'être
noyé dans la bêtise et la médiocrité
humaine
nous voici donc nous petit homme pris
dans la dualité divinité animalité une
forme des taux au final un terrible et
au l'homme étant envisagée comme une
sorte d' instabilité pouvant tantôt se
rapprocher de sa nature bestiale et de
sombrer dans les abîmes tantôt pour
certains être éclairé d'une forme de
lueurs divine
le sortant donc de l'humanité et
l'amener en presque à la frontière du
royaume divin 7 et aux mortels finis
sont évidemment toujours par nous
retirer ce que nous avons de plus
essentiel
notre humanité notre liberté le divin
l'homme et le bestial regrouper ces
trois concepts
voilà le but de la doctrine anti
religieuse car en réalité n'en forment
qu'un
voilà l'objectif de cette lutte contre
eux ce que bakou ni d'appels la folie
collective qu'est la religion dieu et
l'humanité sont donc profondément
antinomiques
car chacun et prédateurs de l'autre si
l'on créé dieu on abîme l'homme si l'on
créé l'homme on abîme dieu voltaire
écrit si dieu n'existait pas il faudrait
l'inventer et bakounine répond si dieu
existait réellement il faudrait bien
évidemment le faire disparaître
[Musique]
ce qui différencie vraiment bakounine
des autres théoriciens socialiste et
collectivistes c'est son anti étatisme
la critique de la religion est en
réalité assez unanime chez les
révolutionnaires mais l'hostilité
drastique de bakounine pour toute forme
d'autorité y compris celle de l'êta
évidemment le différencie fortement
bakounine prouve que l'on peut être de
gauche sans être marxiste ou léniniste
contrairement aux marxistes et aux
communistes il s'oppose à l'état même
durant la phase transitoire entre la
dictature bourgeoise et la société
communiste sans classe ni état il voit
dans ce dernier dans l'état une
institution dangereuse qu'il faudra
abattre dès que l'occasion se présentera
sauf évidemment vouloir prendre le
risque de se voir de voir se développer
une bureaucratie galopante remettant
donc en cause des acquis de la
révolution
l'histoire semble d'ailleurs sur ce
point précis lui donner raison
bakounine refusera d'ailleurs jusqu'à sa
mort le qualificatif de communistes qui
pour le lit signifie par essence le
regroupement du pouvoir dans les mains
de l'état ce qui convient inévitablement
à la négation de la liberté d'un konin
en réalité appelle de ses voeux une
toute autre société une société qui
s'organise de base en eau spontanément
et sûrement pas de haut en bas et de
manière coercitive mais pour le moment
concentrons nous sur ce second ennemi
sur le chemin du grand soir l'état
[Musique]
non
ce qui est frappant dans la pensée
anarchiste de bakounine c'est de trouver
une continuité présenté comme évidente
entre l'église et l'état
le second n'étant qu'une mutation de la
première les états ne sont que des
succursales des églises s'étant adaptée
à la fluctuation des croyances au cours
des époques pour continuer à perpétuer
l'exploitation économique passant d'une
minorité religieuse à une minorité
bénéficiaires dit laïc baconing insiste
fortement sur le parallèle entre le
biberonnage du peuple à grands coups de
mystique religieuse et la fameuse
religion d'état qui imprègne tous les
esprits idéaliste et intellectuel des
matérialistes doctrinaire jusqu'au
communiste allemand et critique
d'ailleurs cette fois dans l'état s'est
développé en même temps que l'adhésion
religieuse décliner c'est donc un
mouvement conjoint
l'un prend le relais de l'autre menant
un combat sur des principes présentés
comme novateur mais qui perpétue bien la
même et unique mission l'oppression des
masses et l'emprise liberticide mais un
point reste tout de même à éclairer et
c'est précisément sur celui ci que nous
proposons de disserter maintenant l'état
possède bien évidemment la force de la
baïonnette
certains diront le monopole de la
violence légitime mais bakounine pense
que la domination de la force ne suffit
pas pour maintenir sur le long terme
une domination aussi injuste qui
légitime sur le peuple pour réellement
imposer le respect à la masse il faut
bien plus qu'une menace physique il faut
une sanction morale simple évidente pour
qu'elle puisse être comprise par
l'ensemble des citoyens
cette sanction morale une fois les
masses mater par la puissance physique
de l'état finira de les soumettre à la
reconnaissance du droit de l'état et de
son autorité morale et quelle est la
force morale la plus puissante la plus
perverse la plus universellement
partagée pour bakounine
évidemment c'est la religion c'est ainsi
qu'en france ce que bakounine appelle la
bourgeoisie voltairienne devenu par son
triomphe de 1830 la classe dominante par
excellence s'est retrouvé à devoir
retrouver une religion alors même
qu'elle avait cru la combattre pour
faire tomber la noblesse catholique mais
évidemment impossible de retourner vers
le catholicisme romain ni non plus vers
le protestantisme
bien que plus conforme à ses aspirations
économiques non il fallait tout autre
chose il fallait une religion plus
discrète moins religieuse pourrait-on
dire une religion qui répondrait à son
absence totale de foie une religion qui
pourraient d'une certaine manière lui
permettre d'atteindre ses objectifs
économiques et politiques
une seule voir et c'est alors
envisageable se retourner vers la
religion humanitaire et révolutionnaire
du xviiie siècle
[Musique]
il n'est pas il ne peut exister d'état
sans religion ça tombe bien notre
bourgeoisie voltairienne vient de
trouver la sienne la religion de son
état mais alors en quoi consiste cette
religion est bien pour bakounine
elle se base sur une réconciliation
celle de la révolution et de la réaction
c'est à dire des principes de la liberté
et de l'autorité évidemment tout cela au
profit du second principe cela va de soi
en réalité cette réconciliation
historique
cette nouvelle religion d'état sert
avant tout la destruction des libertés
populaire au profit de la domination
bourgeoise incarné dans l'état
monarchique puis constitutionnel mais
vous devez vous demander
soit nous voici avec un état et une
mystique religieuse pour légitimer son
autorité mais qui va prêcher la bonne
parole qui va répandre la parole
religieuse de cette nouvelle états à
travers les masses et bien c'est ici que
nous allons retrouver nos intellectuels
idéaliste les deux plus grands d'entre
deux hommes pour lesquels bakounine
réserve sa critique certainement la plus
acerbe et revancharde
les deux prêtres laïcs en robe courte
par excellence robespierre l'esprit le
plus doctrinaire et rousseau l'esprit le
plus faux commençons donc par rousseau
il est décrit par bakounine comme
l'idéaliste moderne par excellence froid
imbu de sa personne
mesquin il est le vrai créateur de la
moderne réaction il inventa l'être
suprême le dieu d'abstrait et stérile
des des listes en apparence l'écrivain
est bien le plus démocratique du xviiie
siècle il couve en lui en réalité le
despotisme impitoyable de l'homme d'état
il fut le prophète de l'état doctrinaire
robespierre quant à lui n'est pas en
reste
il fut son digne et fidèle disciple et
essaya de devenir le grand prêtre de
l'état au nom de ce nouvel être suprême
il guillotine a d'ailleurs à tour de
bras les génies de la révolution et
assassine
jusqu'à et bien son digne héritier et
son digne représentant danton il
préparait alors le triomphe devenu dès
lors nécessaire de la dictature de
bonaparte premier
plus tard d'autres prêcheurs de ce
nouvel état religieux
suivront bakounine cite notamment
benjamin constant madame-de-staël
royer-collard guizot cousin et bien
d'autres qui constitue la première vague
des prêcheurs de cette nouvelle religion
d'état bientôt l'état ne s'appellera
d'ailleurs plus monarchie il s'appellera
république
le nom change mais la forme reste
profondément la même bien entendu
monarchie ou république
il n'en sera pas moins l'état c'est à
dire une tutelle officiellement est
régulièrement établis par une minorité
d'hommes compétents considéré comme
compétent ou des hommes de génie d'homme
dit vertueux éclairé en somme comme
comme dit précédemment tous ses hommes
ont pour mission de est bien de diriger
ce terrible enfants qu'est le peuple à
travers la mystique et la religion de
l'état
bakounine écrit encore une fois à ce
propos les uns sont plus grands que les
autres par le droit divin de
l'inspiration
ce qui constitue aussitôt une inégalité
fixe constante est pétrifié plus inspiré
doivent être écoutés et obéit par les
moins inspirés et les moins inspirés par
les pas du tout inspiré
voilà donc le principe de l'autorité
bien établie et avec lui les deux
institutions fondamentales de l'
esclavage l'église et l'état
fermez la parenthèse à travers l'europe
les idéalistes sont aussi variés que les
que des hommes comme napoléon deux dumas
guizot thiers jules favre pas le temps
jules simon billon premiers et même le
tsar autant d'esprit qui pour bakounine
sont épris d'un idéalisme glacial et
terribles mais vient la troisième vague
plus douce laissant de côté les
serviteurs fanatiques de l'état où l'on
trouve par exemple des êtres plus
distingués diront certains comme
chateaubriand lamartine et même victor
hugo le quasi socialiste semble
s'exclamer bakounine
et à leur suite toute une cohorte
mélancolique et sentimental d'esprit
maigre et pâle qui constitue l'école du
romantisme moderne c'est la littérature
des à montendre délicate distinguer ne
supportant pas le contact brutal des
masses aspirantes au ciel leur patrie et
vivent comme malgré eux sur la terre
c'est romantique ces idéalistes
bien qu'il ne parle pas souvent de
politique quand ils en parlaient et bien
il se montrait souvent franchement
réactionnaire prenant le parti de
l'église contre l'insolence des libres
penseurs des rois contre les peuples et
de tous les aristocrates contre toute la
canaille des rues concernant l'idéologie
de tous ces hommes ou plutôt ce qu'ils
ont en commun
bakounine écrit ces idéalistes marche
sur une vinaigrette philosophique
composé des systèmes les plus opposés un
mélange des pères de l'église des
scolastiques de descartes et de pascal
de kant et des psychologues écossais le
tout superposés sur les idées divine est
inné de platon est recouvert d'une
couche d'immanence hégélienne accompagné
d'une ignorance aussi dédaigneuse que
complète des sciences naturelles et
prouvant que deux fois deux fonds 5 sont
donc ces grands hommes de l'histoire ces
génies vertueux immédiatement inspiré
par dieu m'aime et s'appuyant sur le
consentement universel exprimer
maintenant par le suffrage populaire qui
sont appelés à gouverner les sociétés
humaines
cette nouvelle religion d'état c'est
tout simplement pour bakounine la
nouvelle soupape de sécurité du peuple
qui bien que désespérée et enragé ne
pourra jamais se désengager des chaînes
de ce nouvel ordre moral
rappelez-vous en début de podcasts nous
avions parlé de ce besoin fondamental de
se révolter
et bien aux derniers instants de sa
révolte en admettant que celle ci arrive
l'homme ne pourra trancher la tête de
l'état cet état qu'on lui aura toujours
présenté comme inébranlable sacrés quasi
divin
nous
le
[Musique]
le dieu de ces idéalistes comme nous
l'avons des rires des cris est
absolument nébuleux il ne réchauffe
rien n'est clair c'est un feu follet et
pourtant ces intellectuels que bakounine
qualifie de socialistes bourgeois sienne
alors dieu il s'imagine même que si
celui ci venait à disparaître tous
disparaître est avec lui ainsi ils
perdent du temps à essayer de concilier
l'inconciliable l'humanité et leurs
dieux vie des fantoches mais lors du
existe soyez en sûr
alors évidemment il ne vous le diront
pas comme ça ils préféreront quelques
formules pédante est volontairement
complexifier l'être divin la main la
nature l'architecte le sens l'inconnu
pour bas comme les penseurs idéaliste
modernes ont donc façonné durant près de
trois siècles
cette nouvelle religion usant bien plus
du sentiment abstrait et vaguement
religieux de montage philosophie
complexe et de poésie que de raison ou
d'études scientifiques
toujours dans ce même but faire monter
aux cieux les esprits méritants et
soi-disant éclairé et leurs créations
s'efforçant ainsi de commettre un
dernier larcin religieusement héroïque
il voudrait restituer de nouveau au ciel
à ce divin voleurs aujourd'hui des
masques et tout ce que l'humanité
contient de plus grand de plus beau et
de plus noble dieu existe par la
grandeur seuls des choses qu'ils
inspirent des vers de baudelaire jusqu
aux inventions de galilée
c'est un des ismes discret et humain
mais qu'on s'entende bien des ics tout
de même il est même cause créant
toujours les mêmes effets voilà les
hommes
dirar chizé est soumis de nouveau à dieu
pour baconing en réalité vous trouverez
toujours les idéalistes en flagrant
délit de matérialisme pratique tandis
qu'au contraire vous verrez les
matérialistes poursuivre et réaliser les
aspirations les pensées les plus
largement idéal ouvrons ici une
parenthèse ce qui est très drôle avec
l'affirmation de la commune que nous
venons de citer c'est que c'est
exactement la critique que l'on fait
aujourd'hui au mouvement utopiste
marxiste
où différentes utopie de gauche à savoir
de partir d'un idéal inatteignable et de
terminer dans une forme de régime
autoritaire
car refusant l'imperfection de l'homme
au contraire les capitalistes les
libéraux se vante d'un matérialisme
pratique basée sur l'économie qui permet
d'atteindre une société largement idéal
nous avons donc ici un renversement
rhétorique ont un peu plus de trois
siècles mais fermons la parenthèse
revenons au texte bakounine se bat donc
lui pour le mouvement exactement inverse
contre le dénigrement de l'humanité au
profit de la gloire divine
il voudrait reprendre au ciel les biens
qu'il a dérobé à la terre pour les
rendre à la terre car en privant l'homme
de tout idéalisme
celui-ci se retrouvant dans le royaume
des cieux les socialistes bourgeois
divise les choses humaines et
aboutissent donc au triomphe d'un
matérialisme brutale et cela pour une
raison très simple le divin s'évapore et
monde vers sa patrie le ciel et le
brutal seul reste réellement sur la
terre nous arrivons finalement aux
points névralgiques de la critique
étatiques et donc religieuse de
bakounine et peut-être aussi le prend le
plus riche et stimulant
intellectuellement c'est ce que nous
appellerons la théorie de la chute est
de l'ascension
[Musique]
nous l'avons dit précédemment les
idéalistes en privant les hommes du bo
provoque un matérialisme cruelle et
brutale
au contraire pour bakounine les
matérialistes est vrai comme lui et ses
camarades politiques ce qui hisse bien
haut le drapeau du matérialisme
théorique
le drapeau rouge de l'égalité économique
et de la justice sociale
ceux qui usent de l'idéalisme pratique
pour sortir les masses opprimées et
affamés de leur condition eux tendent à
réaliser la plus grande liberté et le
droit humain de chacun dans la
fraternité de tous les hommes sur terre
eux sont des matérialistes et finissent
par atteindre l'idéal
les autres sont des idéalistes qui
finissent par tomber dans un
matérialisme terrible
autrement dit la vision de l'idéalisme
intellectuelle est une chute continue de
l'idéal humain des ics à une terrible
condition purement matérielles car il
traite avec dédain les choses passagère
mais toute la vie des hommes réels des
hommes en chair et en os n'est composée
que de choses passagère
tout n'est pas grand et beau dans
l'homme au contraire le développement
historique de l'homme selon l'école
matérialiste est une ascension
progressive de la bête à l'homme
humanisé c'est donc la chute contre la
montée la dégringolade contre la grande
marche
bakounine pense partir du réel de
l'animal pour tendre vers l'idéal de
l'humanisation l'idéalisme part de
l'idéal et décline lentement
reflet la société de consommation
l'augmentation de la production à guy
etc ou l'abolition de la peine de mort
ça n'a aucune importance ce qui fait
d'un homme de gauche un homme de gauche
ce n'est pas tel ou tel groupe s est
investi à intégrer n'importe quelle
théorie dans le kit chaque litre en
marche
nous aurions pu évidemment parler de la
société anarchiste proposé par bakounine
de son rejet d'un gouvernement fondée
sur la science de sa vision l'éducation
de la solidarité collective de la
liberté et même pourquoi pas de la place
de la science juste mais ces
développements nous aurait certainement
amenée sur des terrains plus
philosophique que politique
cette première chronique avait
simplement pour but de vous proposer une
dissection de la critique religieuse
étatiques dans un artiste radical je ne
peux à titre personnel que vous
recommandez la lecture de ce petit livre
que vous soyez conservateur radical ou
progressiste convaincu remonter à la
source des idées voilà l'objectif de
cette chronique dans le prochain épisode
je vous proposerai à travers le livre de
raymond aron l'opium des intellectuels
cinq grandes critiques sur la théorie
marxiste et communistes d'ici là vous
pouvez retrouver l'intégralité des
articles et des tribunes de scopeo
l'observatoire politique sur notre site
internet scopeo point org
merci de votre écoute et à bientôt
[Musique]